- There's a scene in the movie
where you get pretty drunk.
Are you method, did you train for this or?
- Always method, Kelly.
- Okay.
- Always method.
- I like it.
I like it.
- I'm an Australian.
- I know, I'm a Texan.
I can hold it, too.
- I bet you can.
- I can hold it back.
- I'm always a big fan
of tasting beverages
from around the world, so,
we got something we're told is
big in Australia these days,
so I don't know if we're
correct, but Justin, thank you.
- Whoa, hello.
Thank you, my friend.
- It's orange wine.
- Ladies and gentlemen.
- Have you heard of orange wine?
- I don't care what it is.
- I don't care.
- Looks good.
This looks great.
- All right.
- Thank you.
- It's apparently big now.
- Cheers, thank you for having me.
Wow, look at this.
Fantastic.
- Is it?
(Kelly and Rose laughing)
- What do you think?
- It's all right.
It a bit dry.
- A bit dry.
What do you like to drink?
What's your?
- Pinot or tequila.
And that's it?
- That's a song.
Let's write that country song.
- Let's go.
Let's chop it up.
- She likes pinot noir or tequila.